welcome to a very special edition of a
beginner breakdown
we are back alright talking about what
else the fried liver two nights the
fence which is apparently better than
the fried liver but my am sorry to
interrupt you guys
I'm like I don't know how to tell you
this but we've decided to go in a
different direction here at the club are
we no longer are going to be doing begin
to break down it's just not working out
look nobody's coming out so we're
canceling the show
man oh man who's that dude the people
have spoken have you read the YouTube
comments
the people's mandate says no more my
color have you not read anything
well who's gonna replace dude anybody
could replace you
just what I could go out of the street
right now I can't find anybody to
replace you
Mike: fine, fine, fine
alright then come with me let's go I
gotta figure this out let's go
ok so are you doing today do we need you
to fill in for a chest class you know
anything about yesterday
that's fine that's fine that's cool just
come on in it's called tactics time you
got this
thank you for the warm welcome one of
the thank all of you guys for coming out
my name is Dennis through this is
tactics time is going to be a series of
lectures where we focus on basic
tactical ideas it's going to be close
and format to begin to break down and
kind of staying true to the roots of the
great tradition of youtube videos that a
the chess club here has been has been
engaged in i'm going to look at a game
essential knowledge for anybody in the
beginner to intermediate level and that
game is the Opera game it's known as the
Opera game between Paul Morphy strongest
American player of the time on and two
French aristocrats more he has the white
pieces in this game in the story is true
i was playing in opera house and he
allowed them to consult with each other
these two aristocrats I any still just
destroyed them on and our goal today is
to identify some of the general
positional ideas that are guiding hit
guiding more feet splay the general
positional ideas on and basic principles
that we use and teach teach beginners
but more importantly than that we're
going to try and find a winning tactics
ok so if you've seen the game feel free
to chime in if you feel that I am i
overlooking something important on for
neglecting that you know an important
sideline a otherwise i hope you guys
going to enjoy going over this as much
as i always do I know it's always
rewarding experience some so we have be
for an e5 on the board and most opening
encyclopedias this is categorized as an
open game on the reason being that the
center typically opens up a little bit
faster and white makes a logical second
move
attacking the e5 square here black is a
number of reasonable options the knight
to c6 is what's most often played on but
the consultants that pic to move it
still gets played to this day on d6
entering the Philidor defense find
destroy a strong pond move that actively
contests the center on black has made it
easy and almost invited white to just
get a nice healthy pawn center and on
established firm lasting control of it
so he does that but I do feel it's kind
of important just to see your implies on
just for a moment because there are a
number of ways that you can proceed and
students especially in the under
thousand one thousand range i see they
all too often want to make really
passive moves here and some of the
better options are like you know a
bishop move to get ready to Castle
kingside or 93 all of these are plate
playable but this is the way to try and
gain a lasting initiative
and here black some black makes a move
that I still seeing the casual play area
when i'm playing blitz this was played
against me the other day and I got
really excited because I knew exactly
what to do here
I and this is another position where i
always ask the students tell me what
what they think is the best move for
white and why so at home you may want to
pause your video this is not this far
from the toughest but the point of
making a puzzle out of this kind of
position is to really ingrain a certain
way of thinking about opening in
developing on in the first remove the
game so anybody in the audience what
didn't you like about capturing
immediately on e5 did you consider that
I believe everyone's agreed on this
being mistake but why why is this a
mistake on and unfortunately a move like
Bishop e2 doesn't necessarily illustrate
the concrete variation which shows that
this move is will leave black with a
permanent disadvantage and the move that
really highlights or accentuates that
weakness is to capture immediately that
in black plays the most straightforward
and logical continuation just
recapturing here losing the e5 pond
there's a danger of losing that e55 on
so if he does recapture directly it
should be clear to those at home and
everyone in the class at this point that
white has this resource that is disposal
you can trade queens on the D file
breaking that pin on the night f3
capture that e5 pawn
and black sees that between the two of
them they will be able to identify that
so like most of us in this room will
play blitz lot and I see a few of you on
this is the kind of decision that we
would make over the board and here you
know
at the risk of being overly remedial I
always ask my students how would you
recapture here seems obvious that you
would capture with the queen but some of
them just haven't quite appreciated yet
that you don't want to double ponds and
and mutilate your pawn structure on for
no good reason
so you certainly do capture with the
Queen here now black can recapture
safely on e5 the whites looking good
here I also pause a lot and I get them
to think about the general ideas in this
opening by bringing up fools mate and
scholars me and I ask them you know what
are the main ideas behind those
obviously you know if they listen to me
they don't they don't try those and in
tournaments because you know they break
a lot of fundamental opening principles
you want to move your queen age 5 you
know on your first or second move on
which is what scholars main Fools may
entail on but we still teach those
mating patterns to students because they
exemplify a theme or an idea which is
always present sometimes it's just
lurking in the background belt often
it's in the foreground of any e4 e5
opening and that that theme is a
favorite of my comers to cover and
talked about on the fried liver attack
it's often referred to as um but I just
think of it as an attack on week seven
on so with that being said I always ask
my students you know what the natural
natural and logical developing move
which attacks f7 which because of the
previous line of play is already under
attack by the Queen on f3 we all know
that what the threat is and we don't now
we do because i'm going to keep using
this cool highlight function here on
this peradventure aristocrats in the
late eighteen hundreds being a
respectable pair of chess players on
aren't too keen on being checkmated on
move 45 whatever this is on how do you
prevent that made on f7 with who
night age 6 is interesting because
instead of just interfering like Jason
suggestion here is interfering with the
Queen's action in your suggested line
he's directly of protecting it right
there's just one little problem that age
6 square is under attack
so what happens if i just take that
night
right yeah exactly and now a sad day for
black but you know this is the reason
that I you know some of us some of us
may say oh that you know this is to
basic to simple know what I mean the
morphe game and all the more fees more
of his game had you know plenty plenty
of ideas and stuff to teach players of
all strength on
so here is Jason suggested they
correctly interposed the knight on f6 ok
more feet is undeterred is determined to
put all of his might
all of this force I'm not it on that f7
square this is the one where I can tell
where you know to me I use the state to
determine how predisposed nose and so my
students are to it
I tell them find a square or find it
find a move that attacks have seven
twice again that renews the attack on f7
the bishop is already attacking of seven
so it can't be a bishop move on the
Queen was attacking of seven tonight on
f6 put a stop to that it's a queen move
find a queen but on b3 we are attacking
of seven the second time and we're
making some other threats as well you
guys feel free to shout them out what
else is is white threatening here on the
light squares
I'm sorry capturing the week b7 pond
right right and its weak as a
consequence of of blacks inaccurate
playing the opening on he made a
thoughtless Bishop move which led you
know led to a line entry in which he was
forced to exchange it for the knight on
f3 and now the light squares are absent
a defender a very important defender
so the problem persists the same problem
f7 is under attack
how does black address this issue
and definitely a home take some time
f7 is under attack we want to defend it
but we've also got another thing to
worry about this is slightly inferior to
what was played in the game
ok and i want the viewers at home and
you in the class to really think about
why on intimate anybody could tell me at
this point that'd be awesome not Claudio
Claudio nose so this
what are we going to do here with black
is there any way to save that rook
you can see six on right yeah but this
is the kind of thing like the details
like Danny's always saying on it's the
little details which make or break it
yeah so you ideas no oh yeah say let's
hear it why why is this better
huh beautiful
yeah to me this is the one one of the
main objective stated when I review this
with students is to make sure that they
they can see that that it because with
black it that the theme is just stubborn
defence yeah you got yourself into a lot
of trouble but you know if white is
careless and thoughtless here gets
greedy and attacks the rook in this
position you can take the steam out of
his attack you'll be down upon but as
the young man in the back and pointing
out you have a forcing little forcing
exchange here mean obviously he has to
do that right unless you want to lose
his Queen on you you you at least
eliminated the red the risk of an early
check mate which is a risk that these
guys are flirting with and ultimately
they succumb to
so lucky luckily for them though they
saw that
morphy being awesome as he was did not
get greedy like myself for many others
at our level would and and take here
thoughtlessly he looked for the best way
to maximize ism already considerable
advantage and he followed just general
principle play which as I said at the
beginning is kind of what we want to
focus on here on we're taught all these
ideas control the center develop rapidly
castle early on but often for whatever
reason we wind up neglecting them on in
our actual games and one reason is that
we don't train ourselves and condition
ourselves to constantly be asking
ourselves whether or not we're playing
by them on what makes a pretty good
excuse me black makes a reasonable at
least defensive move he does not that
want that knight on d5 it will be a
monster there and so he plays c6 totally
understandable morphy staying in line
with these basic principles of opening
play which we were just talking about
develops his final piece in the most
active way possible
creating a pin in black starts to panic
because some of the the issues in his in
his position on namely the fact that the
king is stuck in the center so while
white is exemplifying exemplifying good
opening play black an example of
horrible opening play his King and stuck
in the center for the foreseeable future
on and he has two miners still on the
back row or his white has all of his
miners he has this beautiful development
going on all of his miners off
the back and he has the option of
developing on whichever side he like uh
so he panics he wants to get this Bishop
off the diagonal so that he can move his
queen
you know on a good day get that dark
squared Bishop belt and Castle kingside
on and he makes this horrible losing
move the name of this class is tactics
time pause the video at home have you
never seen this what is the tactical
idea here okay
instead of being passive and retrieving
this Bishop he says no this is the
cornerstone of my whole attack and all
my ideas in this game I will not you
know give up this Bishop this light
squared Bishop without a fight on but
this night however is quite expendable
for the price of two pawns on that's
fine because one of the the benefits are
some of the conversation that i will get
in return is that this king will never
ever castle so he gives up his night
gets his check in there
and I'm sure the players with black
pieces started to get that sinking
feeling in your stomach you know when
i'm in positions like this it's like you
know you almost just start making bad
moves just because you're you know the
momentum is so bad on but here to finish
development with white in the most
logical way
so what's the last stage and development
typically castling castling long kills
two birds with one stone gets our King
safe and adds pressure to this absolute
pin that we've created on d 7 against
the night on d7 with our Bishop b5 maybe
for some of the younger students in the
classroom we can just point out that he
know you must defend this we can't let
white capture in that position on the 7
and here we're near the end at home
going to pause the video spent little
time thinking about this
how would you proceed with light and you
guys in the class you know I really
appreciate some feedback now what do we
think is best here
so like Mario just suggested take and we
can start to see all of our principal
play play start to bear fruit as it were
is a pretty forcing move here on if i'm
not mistaken the engine once you just
take with the Queen at this point and
not get checkmated but these guys didn't
have engines they make that losing
losing move either they made the most
logical position in the most logical
move into position
I'm recapturing with this rook here
fatally weakening the back rank and here
i will not go any further than this talk
just for a second about that again we're
renewing pressure on the pin and here
Black is daydreaming you know he's
hoping that you know why it will have a
lapse of judgment perhaps and allow them
to exchange queens or maybe even
initiate the Queen exchange more if he's
not having it he wouldn't wouldn't have
gotten this far wouldn't have attained
this type of position without knowing
exactly how to proceed here but me I
didn't know how to proceed until it's
spelled out for me
you guys need to find what's up here ok
what do you see
ok the night takes d7 and then what are
you going to play
can you see I just want to workout that
calculation muscle really quick if i put
on the board all right correct forcing
move the ship takes clearly and again I
think the engine is tell you take with
the Queen here don't get don't get
checkmated um but he takes with the
night because he doesn't see the
beautiful forcing matin one here
made into rather excuse me very
impressed that's a lot of people
cheering back there for you all right
good
well done are you sure though you're
giving up the Queen you're positive
alright i'm good i just want to queen
with black pieces didn't I
what do you play here you came huh rook
e8 what what do we call that beautiful
okay that is a forcing me into alright i
hope you guys enjoyed enjoyed watching
that as much as I enjoy going over this
classic and timeless game Paul Morphy za
per game hit like share subscribe on
very open to feedback you guys let us
know what you want you like to see me
cover in this new series tactics time
that we've got going on
okay thanks a lot